gave Trump a raving endorsement at his
campaign rally in that swing state just
take a listen we as Muslims stand with
President Trump because he promises
peace he promised to end war in the
Middle East and Ukraine we support
Donald J Trump for his commitment to
promoting Family Values it was second
and cringe for me but anyway what can we
do here we
go let's talk about life let's talk
about love if we talk about love then we
should talk about us and if we're
talking about us we need to talk about
growth they talk about you what they
should talk about both it's easier to
hate now and harder to care we used to
offer help now we gossip and stare
comment like swipe share hate used to be
R now you see it everywhere mans
beum brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
brothers and sisters do not forget to
check out CED clothing inshallah they've
opened up in Dubai also aldah if you
want to get those Halal clothing for the
sisters and the brothers check them out
in no
thanks free
massage but respect on indeed okay ald
the link is there so we're going to be
reacting to M Hassan questioning the IM
that endorse Trump so we're going to
call him Trump's Imam I thought Mahi was
the
Imam okay yes this is this Mahi ah so
there's multiple mes now yeah no this is
is name name is m okay okay thanks for
clarifying be
M okay so let's go in cuz I'll be honest
with you it was second hand cringe for
me but anyway what can we do here we go
this is his interview with him gave
Trump a raving endorsement at his
campaign rally in that swing state just
take a listen we as Muslims stand with
President Trump because he promises
peace he promised to un war in the
Middle East and Ukraine we support
Donald J Trump for his commitment to
promoting Family Values we as Muslims
support this man because we believe that
he will be a president for all Americans
embracing every race
color Okay so the first one is obviously
there highlights of him and the I mean
did you see that yeah I saw it no now
but you seen it before uh I didn't I've
seen it come up on the feed but I didn't
get a chance to look at it I'll be
honest bro CU it's just the typical
anytime something happens they use like
a token Brown guy the token black guy
you know I mean like token espe the
uncle in the back doing this like it was
just so embarrassing bro and like I
don't know what to say like I it's
embarrassing for Cala
Harris in what way because Trump's got
these guys supporting him irrelevant bro
it's I mean it's I I would not vote
Camal has lost already I don't care man
here is okay here is where he asked him
the Five Points that Donald Trump
promised not the six points yeah let's
see tell us what were the five points
okay so uh uh we focused on five key
points uh things that we believe are uh
critical for the future of uh our
country uh our community and uh you know
even the uh the the world uh president
Trump did not just hear these points uh
he fully acknowledged and and committed
to each uh one of them so what happened
on stage M was really a a public
acknowledgement of this I would say
historical uh agreement because time is
short just briefly tell us what are the
five points just briefly for our viewers
so M and and allow me to say this I mean
I'm surprised that you did not that you
did not see the video and yet on X you
you you posted that this is madness I
don't know based on what you judg that
all me and my colleagues all of these
imams that that Endor Donald Trump that
this is madness and also you you
reposted some of the posts that were
attacking us uh personally so I'm
surprised because you know because
because if you're going to bring up my
post that was about your speech and we
played your speech to the viewers before
it began in your endorsement speech for
Donald Trump you said that Trump quote
promises peace specifically in the
Middle Eastern Gaza this is a man who
when he was president gave Israel
whatever it wanted he moved the embassy
to Jerusalem he legalized the illegal
annexation of the Golan height since the
genocide began in Gaza he said he would
let Israel quote finish the job he's
told nah Who quote do what you have to
do his son-in-law Jared Kushner has said
that Israel should expel Palestinians
from the into the desert so I do believe
it is madness to say that Donald Trump
promises peace when he doesn't promise
peace Trump Stein okay so Benjamin Trump
what would you make out of that a big up
to all the
people that didn't believe in Trump yes
literally yeah bro it's just it's just
so cringe I mean just these videos
aren't even worth watching anytime
something happens
like K did the same thing in his
elections he goes to the mosque and
there's some IM that's representing some
corner of the community that comes out
and wants to favor these people because
they're having a conversation and
they're overruled by them and wants to
endorse them bottom line is we shouldn't
be endorsing either of the two
candidates they're both equally crap
yeah the left wing right wing they're
both wings of the same Bird yeah the
American Eagle that's that's where he is
that's the bottom
line well I mean yeah I mean to me it's
like one of the signs of the hour is
that people who will be in power will be
liars and they will be believed a
truthful person will not be believed and
a liar will be believed so to me it's
like seeing that you know and another
thing is like the prophet said that a
time will come where all nations will
come together and it just shows how weak
we've become that we would even believe
someone like Trump who's a compul
compulsive liar you know he's just lying
continuously so I mean
what else can you say to that you know
what else can you say it's I think it's
a very good lesson for us as well of
course we're supposed to um you know
love our leadership and respect them
however it also goes to show that just
because you're an Imam it doesn't mean
that you're infallible yeah and um it's
very important that we're cautious with
who we take Knowledge from and not just
because oh he's got a beard or I found
him in the mosque or she wears a hijab
or you know they say inshallah and
mashallah therefore you know I can marry
them or therefore I should follow them
or therefore you know I you know I can
blindly just you know go behind what
they're saying I mean not for average
people yes if someone's pass away and
you know their their life is clearly in
front of you then of course follow away
however if someone is alive and you know
you're not paying attention most of your
time is spent at work and you come and
you know
this this is an example mhm exactly I
mean but let's see what was the there
was the third point now where he's kind
of question on yes so the five points
are number one to end the war in the
Middle East especially in Gaza and also
to end the war in the Ukraine that's
number one and we think this is crucial
this is very important and because we as
Muslims I went as an IM and we approach
them as an IM and we think that you know
the religion of Islam is all about peace
and this is what I said in the video we
got number one I just G to hurry because
we won have time to do an interview just
tell us what two three four five are
okay number two is that he promised or
actually uh we demanded that uh you know
that he will protect you know the family
values especially when it comes to
curriculums and school which he made
that clearly in his speeches and also in
his meeting you know the meetings that
he has privately or publicly and also uh
number three that he will that he will
include Muslims that will he will be
inclusive and he will include Muslims in
his cabinet he will include Muslims in
his administration that's number three
number four is that he will tackle he
will fight islamophobia and number uh
and number five I think and number five
we mention things that we agree with the
with the rest of the American people you
know to have a strong economy and to
have also strong borders so you made the
point everyone's heard those are the
points they're very admirable points to
put forward but let's just deal with the
substance of the biggest one the war how
can you say he's a peace candidate or
believe he wants peace when he has not
called for a ceasefire he has not called
for restrictions on arm sales he said
the exact opposite he says Nyah should
be killing more people with less
restrictions let's have a listen to what
Trump says publicly not what he promises
you privately have a listen to what
Donald Trump said the other day who we
play the clip he's doing a good job
Biden is trying to hold him back he
probably should be doing the opposite
actually I'm glad that BB decided to do
what he had to do so Trump is saying
that after 42,000 deaths in Gaza 16,000
kids killed Biden has held Netanyahu
back and he shouldn't have held him back
that he's encouraging Netanyahu not to
to any restraining words from Biden and
that he's praising n for what he did and
this is the man you're ending as the
peace candate I don't get it okay look I
I haven't claimed that President Trump
is a saint or
infallible a peace candidate so let's
just talk about that how is he the peace
candid hold on that's why he said even
in my endorsement I said we are we as
Muslims you know I was talking about my
colleagues on stage and also those
people who trust us and those people
that we repr present which are many by
the way and we said that we are with him
because he promises peace and today by
the way he posted that he want that he
uh you know he will he work you know
when it comes to leanan he will do
everything that with respect with
respect you keep saying this this is
Donald Trump a man who's lied for n
years he's broken every promise he's
ever made he told coal miners he would
save the co mines he didn't save the co
mines he told people at the border he
would build a wall in Mexico Mexico
would pay for it so I'm just wondering
are you being conned IM you're just
believing anything he say what the
listen what is the other party offering
I'm not here to defend the other you
don't have to vote for the Democrats
either I'm just wondering why you vote
for you could vote hold on your stance
and your position your stance and and
your position now from Donald Trump is
based on years of watching him say and
do what do you make of that bro I mean
like it's it's I just see him just kind
of stuttering and like it's like he
knows he shouldn't have done that I
think um factually Mahi seems more on
point with this
that you're taking the word of somebody
who for 9 years has been lying doesn't
have a good track record look at the
sort of stuff that he's saying and
uttering they all go against him so just
because he's made you a few promises
says he's going to do this when he
clearly doesn't have a track record you
being conned and I'm inclined towards
saying yes I think he is being
conned of course man I mean like come on
like I just find it funny he's like yeah
like he genuinely feels like Trump took
him seriously like yeah I spoke to Trump
he Five Points Etc you know this is
sorted out like really bro do you really
believe this like like do you think
Trump is going to come and listen to him
like yeah what's your concerns okay note
that down yeah and you know can you
imagine just Trump in his tone like you
know what yeah that's all sorted out
with just dealt with it now just made
phone calls like I believe he got make
Palestine great again you know exactly
you get what tring to say it's un well
it's unbelievable you guys your masks bu
again exactly exactly it's not
speculation this is what Rudy Giuliani
Trump's very good friend and lawyer said
the day after this is the day after you
endorsed him you Endor him on Saturday
let's listen to what juliani said on
Sunday can we play the clip Hamas is not
there for us Iran is not there for us
they want to kill us and the
Palestinians are taught to kill us at 2
years old they won't let a Palestinian
in Jordan they won't let a Palestinian
in Egypt and how haris wants to bring
them to you so so the day after you
endorse him at his own rally one of his
closest allies is making racist remarks
about Palestinians I mean two-year-olds
this was the most cringiest clip that's
come out in recent times this guy is a
real piece of work wrinkly piece of crap
frankly and he's coming out with twoyear
olds twoy olds can barely string a
sentence together how are they going to
decide who they like or hate they even
hate their own parents who don't give
them their chocolate milk you're saying
that they're hating Israel or they're
hating Jews and what a load of BS bro we
know what he's about my issue is not
about them I know what they're about the
people that do not like Islam enemies of
Islam I know I'm not surprised about
them my concern is this Imam bro this
Imam there like are you this gullible
like really like two days later after
this thing one of Trump's guys saying
this you cannot make this stuff up I
just I'm genuinely like have we become
so inferior that we are going to people
at Trump bro it's second hand
embarrassment bro a secondhand
embarrassment to even be sitting and
there and the most funny thing is that
you actually believe Trump is going to
do that like that's unbelievable but
here's a couple of other Clips in and
we're going to end on it you already you
you already you've done a damage on me
and also on my colleagues the IM and
those who support us when you said this
is madness and you you reposted people
that attacked us personally and now and
to be honest with you I'm shocked I'm
shocked that you did not even see why
did we endorse him I understand why he
made you promises and I'm questioning
why you believe him keep blaming M
Hassan you done this to yourself how are
you blaming M Hassan and saying oh yeah
this cuz he's saying you retweeted those
points so
he's okay it's like me getting caught
doing something that goes like doesn't
benefit the um and then and then nothing
har yeah and then I got people reposting
I go no but why are you reposting it you
brother what I've done is wrong yeah it
was public yeah I'm sorry you get have
you get refuted publicly the point was
islamophobia I think you said one of the
points was to fight islamophobia Donald
Trump is the most islamophobic
politician I've ever come across in my
life he literally said Islam hates us he
incited hatred against ilhan Omar and
Rashid T the only two Muslim women in
Congress they have to have 247
bodyguards because of what Donald Trump
said about them one option is listening
to us is given us is is is lending you
know extending his hand to us and he's
listening to our concerns and also our
aspirations the other party they're not
listening to us let me let me say I
agree with you I agree with you I agree
with the Democrats are not listening
100% I agree can we agree we agree the
Democrats are not listening but that
doesn't mean that he's listening to you
why do you not think he's just exploding
you for votes he's using you is he not
why do you not see that you're not being
a little naive with great politics
politics is all about interest all about
common interest you give me something I
give you something we he's not going to
stop being an islamophobe because you
vote for him I could show you how do you
know that how do you know that you know
you
know or something come on
man what's what's it got to do with the
Unseen brother it's simple y the simp
Things You observe bro it's not a matter
it's not you don't need to be a smart
ass like you know oh you know what it's
the Unseen I've got some sick sense
brother it's in front of you do you not
see what it is yes hope that Trump would
would do good you can't make this
stuff you like hope Al ah bro we saw
what he did in office when he was in
office he didn't just support the
oppression of the Palestinians he
supported the Saudi Le war in Yemen
which I believe is a country you're from
uh he overa its deadliest most VI
started under Obama but he overso its
deadliest most violent year 2018 tens of
thousands of innocent yees were killed a
school bus in Yemen famously was blown
up 40 children killed by a us made bomb
less than a year later Congress tried to
stop the war Trump refused he bypassed
Congress he gave Saudi Arabia NBS more
weapons to kill yemenis with you are a
yemeni American how do you vote for
someone who has so much yemeni blood on
his the fact that he goes like do you
know the Unseen um you don't know but
he's basically saying there's a hope
that because he's sat with
as human beings well was this is what
happens when inferiority complex hits
you yeah like sitting with Donald Trump
cuz you get this oh my gosh the
president of the United States sitting
in front of me who cares bro who cares
he cares I don't care if he cares bro
he's there just saying oh yeah he's got
braa and the guy holding up the peace
sign he cares for God's sake and the
thing is he oh yeah he's like we sat
with him and he yeah a what are you
talking about W I do my brain I'm just
genely thinking this is is this comedy
it's this com I gen thought when the
first thing happened it's like some just
random guy he not even a Muslim it's
just a random guy he's an actual IM I
mean I I don't I don't the back by I'm
just saying this is unbelievable this is
unbelievable and right so he could be
the guy who changes Donald Trump and you
don't even realize it he thinks because
with him I think he's fixed Donald Trump
bro bro he thinks he's fixed he thinks
that that's the most na part he goes how
do you know that he's after he spoken to
us he's going to be okay with the
Muslims again braa what do you offer him
bro what did you think he cares about
you he kills your people you're yemeni
you're yemeni bro and me right so just
explain to you he's the one who's
funding the NBS and what was going in
Yemen and now you're here you can't make
this stuff up bro like I I'm I'm shocked
I'm speechless I don't know what to say
about it I mean you guys make a decision
I don't know is anything like you like
to say yeah what m is he the IM should
pay just give him a high five give him
the PE sign what could you say aldah but
yes brother sisters I hope you guys
enjoy this as much as we did but
[Music]